[Musica]
argomento della chiacchierata di questa
sera che la contrapposizione tra uno
spazio fisico è uno spazio digitale
quindi un ambiente un ambiente fisico
nel quale siamo abituati a vivere un
ambiente digitale
il soggetto di questo film era
abbastanza particolare perché avevamo
dell'entità digitali in particolare dei
robot che si muovevano nello spazio
fisico nella realtà fisica quella che
abitiamo tutti i giorni ma lo facevano
pilotati da delle persone che per
poterli in qualche modo guidare
all'interno di questo punto mondo mondo
fisico avevano necessità di
interfacciarsi a loro volta in un mondo
virtuale quindi se vogliamo è un
soggetto assolutamente fighissimo di
vista cinematografico infatti il film è
molto carino non so se avete avuto modo
di vederlo
però anche un'idea piuttosto piuttosto
contorta
quello che sicuramente non è contorto e
il fatto che
stiamo già in qualche modo vivendo una
cosa del genere nel senso che passiamo
le nostre giornate in uno spazio di uno
spazio fisico ci alziamo la mattina ci
muoviamo facciamo tutte le nostre cose
però in realtà muoviamo tantissime
azioni della nostra giornata in uno
spazio digitale ce ne rendiamo conto
quando magari andiamo a vedere il report
che ci fa il nostro cellulare a fine
giornata dove vediamo che abbiamo
passato
tantissima parte della nostra giornata
tra email social
videoconferenza eccetera eccetera quindi
in realtà c'è già una stretta
comunicazione tra questi due mondi tra
il mondo fisico e il mondo il mondo
digitale io vi chiedo scusa perché lo
ripeterò fino alla nausea questo fisico
e digitale lo farò fino fino alla fine
però è proprio è proprio vero c'è una
sottile membrana che diciamo separa
questi due mondi che sta diventando
sempre più permeabile per cui elementi
del belluno vanno a confluire nell'altro
e viceversa facciamo partire il video
video numero due
è vero per esempio che siamo
perfettamente in grado di creare dei
mondi dei mondi virtuali
quindi li possiamo modellare sulla base
di
opere di fantasia
come per esempio in questo caso possiamo
fare una passeggiata su marte e lo
possiamo fare inventandoci tutto di sana
pianta oppure magari prendendo anche
degli elementi reali quindi in questo
caso per esempio le mappe del terreno
quindi la morfologia del terreno le
caratteristiche il colore così via
dicendo sono scaricate direttamente
dalle mappe che mi sa che mi mette a
disposizione dalla nasa sul suo sito
quindi sono comunque di elementi reali
elementi reali e come anche presi in più
il robot che avete visto i vari elementi
modulari e così via dicendo e quindi
milano la possibilità per esempio di
fare una passeggiata in un ambiente che
non avrò mai in vita mia la possibilità
di vedere
di persona diciamo così perché
sicuramente non sarà la mia generazione
quella che riuscirà ad andare su su
marte
la stessa cosa la posso fare però
andando a riprodurre degli ambienti
reali degli ambiti che esistono diciamo
nella nella realtà e li possono
riprodurre in maniera assolutamente
fedele come opere come opere virtuali
questo lo posso fare anche grazie a
tecniche che ormai sono
consolidate assolutamente diciamo
efficaci come per esempio la
fotogrammetria che grazie al
alla possibilità di scattare un certo
numero di foto all'interno di un oggetto
in questo caso di
monumenti archeologici
ci dà la possibilità di ricostruire una
mesh quindi ricostruivano insieme di
poligoni che sono la riproduzione
assolutamente fedele di quella di quella
di quella location questo lo posso fare
per i motivi più disparati per esempio
per promuovere una località fini a fini
turistici posso anche utilizzare della
fotografia 360 gradi per andare magari a
catturare degli elementi che vado a
mettere come come come contorno allo
skyline e quindi ci sono tutti gli
strumenti per riuscire veramente a
ricreare un ambiente virtuale che
un'esatta fe delle coppie di un ambiente
di un ambiente reale la cosa ancora più
interessante se vogliamo è che poi posso
andare a visitarlo questo ambiente
questo ambiente virtuale quindi se
indosso un casco per la per la realtà
virtuale posso magari andare a camminare
realmente in quei quei posti in quegli
spazi e posso andare interagire con
l'ambiente quindi corso attraverso l'uso
di controller andare a raccogliere degli
oggetti
spostarmi camminare
magari fare anche delle scalate su in
questo caso abbiamo un uragano che non
potrei anche fare nella realtà se non mi
arrestano giustamente
maggiore l'interazione con questi con
questi elementi l'interazione che io in
questi spazi virtuali
maggiore sarà il senso di immersività
che andrò a provare e quindi tanto più
diciamo interessante appagante sarò
l'esperienza che avrò provato quando
avrò diciamo effettivamente indossato
questo questo caschetto questo concetto
lo possiamo anche portare ancora più
avanti nel senso che possiamo anche
interagire tra di noi all'interno di uno
spazio virtuale quindi io potrei
conoscere incontrare delle altre persone
che magari come me indossano un
caschetto si trovano nello stesso spazio
e potremmo anche condividere diciamo la
stessa esperienza ma posso anche
estremizzare incontrare delle persone
che apparentemente sono delle persone in
realtà sono delle intelligenze
artificiali
quindi io potrei tranquillamente
colloquiare con un intelligenza
artificiale in linguaggio naturale
quindi assolutamente spontaneo non con
frasi preconfezionate ma così come mi
viene in mente diciamo di
parlarci e magari avere delle
informazioni che adesso riguardo il
posto in cui mi trovo quindi potrei
incontrare un ipotetica guida turistica
come per esempio questa vediamo l'altro
video
salute
posso raccontarti qualche storia
sì grazie
di cosa vuoi che ti parli dei villaggi
nuragici e dei nuraghi delle tombe dei
giganti delle domus de janas dei pozzi
sacri parlamento in uranio
un nuraghe è una torre di pietra
costruita se col 33 mila anni fa ne
esistono di mono torre di polilobata
principalmente sono di due tipi nuraghe
a torre o nuraghi a corridoio
parlami del figlio di anpas il monumento
attuale quello romano scoperto dal
generale la marmora nel
costruito in più fasi con pietra
calcarea locale
restano in piedi la gradinata d'accesso
e il podio ornato da eleganti colonne
perfettamente allineate quando è stato
costruito
il primo tempio risale al 500 avanti
cristo
la costruzione del tempio romano risale
al primo secolo avanti cristo
ecco se vi sembra che la signorina sia
un po diciamo
artefatta poco umana in realtà pensate
che un progetto che ha già un paio di
anni questa in realtà è la tecnologia
che siamo in grado di esprimere in
questo momento
e questi sono i nuovi avatar quindi in
qualche modo se ci fate caso
assomigliano sempre di più una persona
siamo sempre più estremizzando questo
concetto arriveremo al punto che
all'interno di un ambiente virtuale
potremmo incontrare
soggetto come quello non riuscire a
distinguerlo perché nello stesso tempo
aveva fatto ancora ulteriori passi
l'intelligenza artificiale per cui non
riuscivamo neanche a capire se stiamo
colloquiando con una persona avere una
persona digitale diciamo così
quindi diciamo siamo perfettamente in
grado come esseri fisici di trasporti in
un in un ambiente virtuale in un
ambiente digitale abbiamo tutti gli
strumenti per farlo
però è vero anche il contrario cioè c'è
sempre questo dualismo è vero anche la
possibilità che un un'entità digitale
venga a
ad abitare uno spazio fisico vediamo
l'altro video per esempio in questo caso
abbiamo un'unità digitale un robot
diciamo un carrellino motorizzato ma in
realtà è un vero e proprio computer
ricco di sensori un'unità robotica a
tutti gli effetti che si muove
all'interno di un ambiente fisico ma per
muoversi all'interno di un ambiente
fisico lo faccio i comandi che gli
permettono di
tracciare i percorsi
fare queste rotazioni muoversi
all'interno di questo ambiente gli
vengono dati da un suo alter ego
virtuale che si muove all'interno di uno
spazio virtuale che in realtà è una
sovrapposizione 1 1 con lo spazio fisico
quindi facendo questo mi rendo conto che
un po contorto l'idea è un po un po
strana però ci abbiamo creduto fino in
fondo e crs4 il posto in cui in cui
lavoro conosciuto di ricerca
multidisciplinare siamo anche riusciti a
depositare un brevetto su questo su
questo argomento
questo perché effettivamente queste
unità robotica riesce non solo a
muoversi a raggiungere una determinata
destinazione ma riesce anche grazie
all'applicazione che abbiamo fatto a
evitare degli ostacoli anche dinamici
che vengono a interporsi nel suo nel suo
percorso
ovviamente c'è un intelligenza
artificiale che permette di calcolare
quello che il miglior percorso che deve
ottenere una volta che magari si è
presentato un ostacolo e raggiungere
comunque le mette le destinazioni che si
era prefissato quindi è vero che noi
esseri fisici tra virgolette possiamo
muoverci all'interno di uno spazio
virtuale ma è vero l'abbiamo visto che
anche uno spazio un entità fisica
digitale può muoversi in uno spazio in
uno spazio fisico
ovviamente di esempi ce ne possono
essere tantissimi ho attinto qualcosa
dalla mia esperienza professionale però
ci possono essere rispetto a questo
dualismo ci possono essere veramente
mille esempi perché ci sono mille esempi
e perché soprattutto è interessante
questo questa diciamo questa fusione tra
ambiente fisico ambiente digitale perché
oggigiorno ha un nome a un nome che è un
po diciamo sulla bocca di tutti si
chiama metaverso che è una delle keyword
più qualche modo utilizzate di recente
anche grazie all'annuncio che ha fatto
mark zuckerberg il 4 il padrone di
patron di facebook che ha cambiato il
nome da facebook a meta e quindi tutti
parlano del natale attraverso in fin dei
conti a una definizione che proprio la
fusione tra un ambiente fisico un
ambiente digitale
coadiuvata dall utilizzo di internet
questa diciamo dai la e la destinazione
definizione più sintetica che ci può
essere di meta verso in realtà la parola
metà versa una parola che per la prima
volta è apparsa nel 1992 non è nulla di
nuovo se vogliamo è apparsa in un
romanzo di fantascienza ex chiamavano
crash
dove per la prima volta si vedeva un
personaggio che indossava un caschetto
di realtà virtuale e trascorreva la
maggior parte della sua giornata dentro
un ambiente digitale piuttosto che
nell'ambiente fisico
quindi perché adesso diciamo sta
diventando sempre più importante questo
questo concetto di metaverso perché
fondamentalmente
ci stiamo rendendo conto che è
l'ulteriore passo evolutivo è qualcosa
che a cui comunque in qualche modo
arriveremo
avremo un solo metaverso avremo tanti
metaverso per il momento c'è sicuramente
un po di confusione ma di sicuro
potremmo avere tanti diversi metà versi
è anche tante declinazioni del metaverso
quindi potremmo avere il metaverso
virtuale quello che abbiamo visto più o
meno l'inizio indossiamo il caschetto
andiamo in un ambiente digitale
completamente estranei estraniandoci
completamente dell'ambiente che è che
stiamo vivendo in quel momento dello
spazio fisico che stiamo vivendo in quel
momento
oppure possiamo avere un'età versa
aumentato e cioè indossare un occhiale
di realtà aumentata diciamo così che è
un occhiale che comunque mi permette di
continuare ad avere un contatto con la
realtà con quello che ho intorno a me ma
mi aggiunge diciamo degli elementi
magari
tridimensionali o comunque anche delle
altre cose che mi danno degli elementi
di intrattenimento piuttosto che
l'informazione o quant'altro quindi
possiamo sicuramente anche avere diversi
tipi di me attraverso
tutto questo per diciamo gli addetti ai
lavori per anche le persone non tecniche
ma che comunque magari che nei suoi
gamer le persone che a cui piacciono
piacciono i videogiochi vivono poi di
videogiochi
sono concetti sembra di vedere un film
già visto in qualche modo ma anche
diciamo forse qualcun altro si ricorderà
un progetto che si chiamava secondlife
che un progetto del 2003 che
effettivamente era erap era proprio
esprimere lo stesso concetto quindi
avevamo una seconda vita digitale
passavamo del tempo e questa seconda
vita digitale c'erano persone che
saranno fatte una famiglia una casa
degli amici nella seconda quindi a
livello concettuale e tutto già visto in
qualche modo perché quindi adesso ci
deve interessare questo momento verso
perché ci interesserà questo metaverso
allora le ragioni secondo me sono
tantissime è una e una materia
sicuramente molto complessa e molto
articolata io però mi sono fatto mi sono
diciamo
chiarito tre concetti sono tre punti che
secondo me sono
importanti
allora anzitutto adesso abbiamo il
bisogno del metaverso prima non ce
l'avevamo adesso ce l'abbiamo cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che abbiamo bisogno di
avere nuovi strumenti di comunicazione
l'abbiamo visto anche in base
recentemente voglio dire la stiamo
ancora vivendo la pandemia tutti voi
avete la mascherina sappiamo bene cosa
vuol dire comunicare utilizzare anche
strumenti di videochiamata
cose di questo tipo e sappiamo bene
anche quali sono i limiti di questi
strumenti e sappiamo che sarebbe
assolutamente
molto più appagante avere degli
strumenti che ci permettono di avere
un'interazione molto più semplice molto
più facile con una persona che magari
sta dall'altra parte del mondo anche
magari semplicemente dall'altra parte
della città quindi avere nuovi strumenti
di comunicazione è un bisogno è
sicuramente vorrei il metaverso può dare
una risposta in questo senso
l'altro bisogno è che se ci fate caso
abbiamo necessità di un evoluzione di
internet in generale del web in
particolare ora se ci fate caso il web
dal 92 93 non si è evoluto più di tanto
è cambiato tantissimo quello sì però per
esempio il concetto di ipertesto che in
realtà non è un concetto nuovo per per
la storia non è stato inventato
introdotto con la nascita del world wide
web quando è stato diciamo creato il
primo browser nel 1993 94 è un concetto
molto più antico però è vero che si è
perfezionato
l'ipertesto di internet le pagine le
pagine web e quant'altro ma a livello
concettuale non è cambiato rimasto
sempre uguale quindi non c'è stata
nessuna evoluzione quindi anche avere
un'evoluzione in quel senso un
evoluzione di una di uno strumento che
usiamo tutti i giorni che comunque
rimasto bidimensionale se ci pensate è
un bisogno è un bisogno naturale
dell'uomo il vedere cambiare l'evolversi
delle cose quindi abbiamo una necessità
dall'altra parte abbiamo la tecnologia
che può rispondere a questa necessità
ora ce l'abbiamo ce l'abbiamo molto di
più rispetto all
90 dal 2003 scusate quando l'ho
conosciuto a second life
abbiamo tantissimi una capacità di
calcolo
basta vedere i telefonini che abbiamo in
tasca sono opta coro cose di questo tipo
quindi abbiamo tantissime la capacità di
calcolo abbiano delle infrastrutture di
rete potentissime con la fibra con i
link via satellite quant'altro forse
abbiamo ancora anzi sicuramente abbiamo
ancora un limite tecnologico e un punto
di vista dell'hardware perché il
principale driver che dovrebbe che
dovrebbe diciamo facilitare il metaverso
che sono questi occhiali che in qualche
modo sostituiscono il display lo schermo
che adesso il nostro telefonino e lo
schermo con cui facciamo la maggior
parte delle interazioni digitali quello
schermo verrà sostituito da un occhiale
che potrà essere un occhiale immersiva
un occhiale aumentato quelli che abbiamo
adesso sono sono pesanti sono scomodi
sono creano problemi di motion sickness
sono molto costosi quindi sicuramente mi
un problema di hardware ma è un problema
che nel giro di 5 anni 6 anni
risolveremo gli analisti stimano queste
queste questo lasso di tempo c'è diciamo
anche ci sono anche quelli più
ottimistiche dicono che nel giro di tre
anni dovremmo veramente riuscire ad
avere degli occhiali che assomiglieranno
sempre di più degli utili dalla lista
degli occhiali da sole che in realtà ci
daranno tutte le funzionalità che ci
servono e tutte quelle che abbiamo
descritto prima per poter effettivamente
accedere a questa nuova dimensione
l'ultimo punto è il fatto che
finalmente abbiamo uno strumento abbiamo
una serie di strumenti che ci tutelano
che restano diciamo a a creare fiducia
noi abbiamo diciamo accedendo a metà
verso soprattutto nel caso in cui averne
tanti diversi
abbiamo la necessità di tutta l'area non
offre identità digitale quindi la
possibilità di riuscire ad avere in
maniera univoca università digitale e
poterla trasportare magari dome
attraverso all'altro ma anche di
possedere dei beni venderli da avere
degli asset digitali che rimangono
univoci e tutto questo è possibile
grazie alla boccia alla block chain in
effetti è di smart contrast e
quant'altro è sicuramente una una
un altro dei driver che porteranno
diciamo la diffusione di questo di
questo strumento io per concludere
volevo leggervi la frase è visto che ho
rubato dal mondo digitale una clip come
introduzione robot dal mondo fisico
una frase da un libro che il 1984 di
george orwell che insomma è un
capolavoro della letteratura che ci ha
lasciato tantissimi spunti di
riflessione e questa frase estrapolata
dal contesto quindi non voglio dare un
significato ben preciso mi piace perché
si presta a più interpretazioni e ognuno
di voi può dargli la propria non dirò
quella che è la mia interpretazione
solo una mente disciplinata può davvero
discernere la realtà tu pensi che la
realtà sia qualcosa di oggettivo di
esterno qualcosa che abbia un esistenza
autonoma credi anche che la natura della
realtà sia di per se stesse evidente
quando inganni te stesso pensi di
vederne qualcosa tu presumi che tutti
gli altri vedano ciò che vedi tu ma io
ti dico winston che la realtà non è
qualcosa di esterno la realtà esiste
solo nella mente in nessun altro luogo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]